The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
Today we do a somewhat
computational bit.
And actually, the
lecture for today
is not nearly as
difficult, once you
get through the
maze of symbolism,
as it is to apply the material.
In other words, we're going
to devote the next two
units of our course to this
particular topic, which
is known as the chain rule.
But we'll give one lecture
to cover both units.
And again, the idea is
that it's not so much
that the concept becomes
more difficult as much as it
is that you must
develop a certain amount
of dexterity keeping track of
the various partial derivatives
and the like.
At any rate, maybe
I think the best way
is to just barge into a
hypothetical situation
and see what the
situation really is.
The idea is essentially
the following.
We're given some
function, say, w.
w is a function of, say, the
three independent variables
x, y, and z.
Now, for some reason
or other, which
we won't worry
about right now, it
turns out that x, y,
and z are, in turn,
conveniently expressible in
terms of the two variables
r and s.
In fact, if you want a physical
interpretation of this,
you can think of if x,
y, and z are functions
of the two independent
variables r and s,
that means that we have
two degrees of freedom.
So we may think of this as
parametrically representing
the equation of a surface.
And what we're
talking about here
is w being a function of
something in space and asking,
what does w look like when
you restrict your space
to a particular surface?
I mean, that's just a
geometrical interpretation
that one could talk about.
But the idea is the following.
After all, if w depends
on x, y, and z, and x, y,
and z each depend on r
and s, in particular then,
it's clear that w itself is
some function of r and s,
where, again, I use
the usual notation
of using a g here
rather than the f
up here to indicate that the
relationship between r and s
which specifies w,
may very well be
a different algebraic
relationship than that which
relates x, y, and z to give w.
But the point that we have
in mind is the following.
Given that w is a
function of x, y,
and z, given that x, y, and
z are functions of r and s,
hence w is a
function of r and s.
The question that we ask in
calculus of several variables
is, first of all, if we can
be sure that these were all
continuously
differentiable functions,
can we be sure that w will be
a continuously differentiable
function of r and s?
That's the first question.
And the second question
is, OK, assuming
that the answer to the first
question is in the affirmative,
that w is a continuously
differentiable function of r
and s, how could we compute,
for example, the partial of w
with respect to r, knowing
all of the so-called obvious
other partial derivatives?
What do I mean by that?
Well, what I mean is if you were
to look just at this equation,
just looking at
this equation, what
are the obvious partial
derivatives to take?
You say, well, we'll
take the partial of w
with respect to x, the partial
of w with respect to y,
and the partial of
w with respect to z.
And if you were to look,
say, at this equation,
the natural thing to ask
is, what is the partial
of x with respect to r?
What is the partial of
x with respect to s?
Et cetera.
In other words, what
we're saying is,
in this particular problem, we
would like to figure out how,
for example, to compute the
partial of w with respect
to r, knowing that we
have at our disposal
the partials of w with
respect to x, y, and z;
the partials of x, y, and z
with respect to r; et cetera;
meaning we also have
the partials of x, y,
and z with respect to theta.
Before I go any further,
notice, by the way,
that if I left out that
phrase that we were talking
about in our last lecture,
"continuously differentiable,"
notice that all of
this would make sense,
provided that the
derivatives existed.
There was no place here
do I make any statement
that the partials have to not
only exist but be continuous.
I never say that at all.
This is what the problem is.
I would like to
use the chain rule.
Do you see why it's
called the chain rule?
w is a function of x, y, and z.
x, y, and z are each
functions of r and s.
Now, what I claim is that
not only is it possible
to do this but the
recipe for doing
this is a very, very suggestive
thing, one which is very, very
easy to remember, once you
see how it's put together.
If you don't see how
it's put together,
the thing is just
a mess-- namely,
the claim is that the partial
of w with respect to r
is the partial-- I'll just read
it to you-- the partial of w
with respect to x times the
partial of x with respect to r,
plus the partial
of w with respect
to y times the partial
of y with respect to r,
plus the partial
of w with respect
to z times the partial
of z with respect to r.
And as I say, if you
try to memorize that,
it's a very, very
nasty business.
But let's look at this
in three separate pieces.
In a way, can you
sense that this
is nothing more than the
change in w with respect
to r due to the
change in x alone?
In other words, you're
taking here what?
The change in w due to
x and multiplying that
by the change in x
with respect to r.
So this is the contribution of
the change in w with respect
to r due to x alone.
On the other hand, this is
the partial of w with respect
to r due to the
change in y alone.
And this is the partial
of w with respect
to r due to the
change in z alone.
And since x, y, and
z are independent,
the change in x, the change
in y, and the change in z
are also independent variables.
Consequently, it seems
reasonable to assume
that to find the total change
of w with respect to r,
we just add up all of the
partial contributions.
Namely, we take the
partial of w with respect
to r due to x alone, add
on to that the partial of w
with respect to
r due to y alone,
add on to that the
partial of w with respect
to r due to z alone,
and that that sum should
be the total change
in w with respect r,
treating s as a constant.
And by the way, let me point out
a pitfall with this notation.
We're so used to using
fractional notation here.
Have you noticed that if
you're not careful here,
you're almost
tempted to cancel--
I don't want to write this,
because you'll think that it's
the right way of doing it.
But see if we say, let's cancel
the partials with respect
to x here, let's cancel
to y here, and let's cancel
the partials with respect
to z here.
By the way, if you did that,
notice what you would get
is the contradiction that the
partial of w with respect to r
is equal to the partial
of w with respect
to r, plus the partial
of w with respect to r.
In other words,
it seems that you
would get that the partial
of w with respect to r
is always three
times itself, which
is, I hope, a glaring enough
contradiction so I don't
have to go into any more detail
about the contradiction part.
Notice again, though, why
I have made such a fetish
over labeling the variables.
Notice that when you're
taking the partial of w
with respect to x, you're
assuming that y and z
are the variables that
are being held constant.
And when you're taking the
partial of x with respect to r,
it's s that you're assuming
is being held constant.
And as soon as you look
at these subscripts here,
somehow or other that
should put you on your guard
to be careful about crossing
out because, after all,
the changes are being
made with respect
to different sets of variables.
At any rate, this
is the statement.
And my other claim is that
the proof follows immediately
from the main, key theorem that
we stressed last time, even
though we didn't prove it.
But we've had ample
exercises using this.
Namely, notice that
we have already
seen that if w does happen to
be a continuously differentiable
function of x, y, and z, then
delta w is the partial of w
with respect to x times delta
x, plus the partial of w
with respect to y times delta
y, plus the partial of w
with respect to z times
delta z, plus an error term.
And what is that error term?
It's k_1 delta x, plus k_2
delta y, plus k_3 delta
z, where k_1, k_2,
and k_3 all approach
0 as delta x, delta y,
and delta z approach 0.
Now again, the key
step in all of this
is that this amount here I
could always call delta w tan,
or as Professor Thomas calls
it for more than two variables,
delta w sub lin, l-i-n, meaning
that this is a linear equation.
Remember-- I've made
an abbreviation here--
these partials are assumed to be
evaluated at a particular point
that we're interested in.
But the idea is, granted that
I can always call this delta w
tan, to say that the error has
this small a magnitude depends
on the fact that w is a
continuously differentiable
function of x, y, and z.
That's why the theory
is so important.
What happens in real life
is that most examples
you encounter in real-life
engineering, the functions
that you're dealing with are
continuously differentiable.
So it seems like we're making
a big issue over nothing.
I should point out that on
the frontiers of knowledge,
enough situations occur where
the functions that we're
dealing with are not
continuously differentiable,
that some horrible mistakes can
be made by assuming that you
can replace delta w by this,
without any significant error.
But as long as this is
the case, we can do this.
And now notice, what does the
partial of w with respect to r
mean?
It means you take delta
w divided by delta r.
And let me just do that here.
I'll just divide
every term by delta r.
And now, what do I have to
do next to get the partial?
I have to take the limit
as delta r approaches 0.
Now the interesting point
is as delta approaches 0,
holding s fixed, this
term obviously becomes
the partial of x with
respect to r, by definition.
This term becomes the partial
of y with respect to r,
by definition.
And this term becomes a
partial of z with respect to r,
by definition.
By the way, notice that even
though delta x, delta y,
and delta z are all going
to 0 as delta r goes to 0,
you can not immediately conclude
that these terms drop out.
Because after all, delta
r is also approaching 0.
So delta x over delta r
is that 0 over 0 form.
In fact, that's
precisely the partial
of x with respect to r term
that we're talking about.
The beauty is what?
That as delta x,
delta y, and delta z
approach 0, each of
the k's approach 0.
You see, the reason that the
error term becomes negligible,
becomes 0 in the limit, isn't
because delta x, delta y,
and delta z are becoming small.
Because these small
numbers are being divided
by another small number.
It's because the k_1, k_2,
and k_3 are getting small.
At any rate, putting
this all together,
notice that now, in
a manner completely
analogous to our part-one
treatment of the chain rule,
except that we're now dealing
with several variables,
these three terms drop out.
And these three terms become
the claim that we made before.
In other words, this is how the
partial of w with respect to r
is computed.
And again, the theory is
the easiest part of this.
That's the easy part.
The hard part is
getting familiarity
with how to work with this.
And I think the best way
to get some familiarity
for working with this is to pick
particularly simple problems
for the lecture,
problems where it's
so easy to do the
problem both ways
that no hangup can
possibly occur.
Let's take a very
simple example.
Let's suppose that
w equals x squared
plus y squared plus z squared.
Suppose we also know that x
is r plus s, y is r minus s,
and z happens to be 2r.
In this particular
case, notice that we
would find the partial of w with
respect to r very conveniently
by direct substitution.
Namely, we simply
replace x by r plus s,
we replace y by r minus
s, we replace z by 2r.
And then w simply becomes
this expression here,
which when we collect
terms, becomes
6 r squared plus 2 s squared.
And again, the arithmetic
there is simple enough
so I'm not even going to
bother worrying about how
we justify these steps.
At which stage, to take the
partial of w with respect to r,
holding s constant,
this is simply what?
12r.
Because s is being
treated as a constant,
its derivative with
respect to r is 0.
You see, in an
example like this,
one would not really be
tempted to use the chain rule.
The chain rule is
used in many cases
not just for convenience,
but in cases of great theory
where you're only given that
w is some function of x, y,
and z, and you're
not told explicitly
what the function is.
You're just given f of x, y, z.
In the case where the
function is given explicitly,
it's sometimes very easy
to substitute directly.
At any rate, what the chain
rule says is roughly this.
They say, lookit.
From this equation,
you could immediately
say the partial of w
with respect to x is 2x,
the partial of w with
respect to y is 2y,
respect to z is 2z.
From this equation,
you could immediately
say that the partial of
x with respect to r is 1,
the partial of x with
respect to s is 1,
the partial of y with
respect to r is 1,
respect to s is minus 1,
the partial of z with
respect to r is 2,
and the partial of z
with respect to s is 0.
In particular, summarizing our
results, we have these here.
Now, what the chain
rule says is what?
To find the partial of
w with respect to r,
you just take the
partial of w with respect
to x times the partial
of x with respect to r,
plus the partial
of w with respect
to y times the partial
of y with respect to r,
plus the partial
of w with respect
to z times the partial
of z with respect to r.
And if we do that in this
case, we simply get what?
2x plus 2y plus 4z.
Now again, I picked,
deliberately,
a very simple problem here.
Remember, by definition, x
is r plus s, y is r minus s,
and z happens to be 2r.
And now you can see very quickly
here that when I substitute in,
I get what?
2r plus 2r is 4r, plus 8r is
12r, and 2s minus 2s is 0.
The partial of w
with respect to r
is also 12r, also meaning what?
We found that same
answer before.
At least that's how
the chain rule works.
And again, we have to remember
that the chain rule does not
depend on the
number of variables,
even though this may start
to look a little bit sticky.
Let's word it as follows.
Suppose w happens to be a
continuously differentiable
function of the n independent
variables x_1 up to x_n.
See, that's what this
parenthetical remark means.
I'm saying that not only do
the partials of f with respect
to x_1 up to x_n exist
at a given point,
but they are continuous there.
And why do I want that in there?
So I can say that my
error term is never
any greater than that k_1
delta x_1, plus k_2 delta x_2,
plus, et cetera, k_n delta
x_n, where the k's go
to 0 as the delta x's go to 0.
I'm going to spare you
the details of proofs.
But I just want
you to keep seeing
why these things are necessary.
At any rate, let's suppose now
that each of the n variables
x_1 up to x_n turn out to be
functions of the m variables.
n and m could
conceivably be equal.
But m could even be more than n.
It can be less than n.
There's no reason why
they have to be equal.
All we're saying is, speaking
in the most general terms,
suppose each of the n x's is
a continuously differentiable
function of the m independent
variables y sub 1 up
to y sub m.
In fact, that's what this
"et cetera" means here.
The "et cetera" refers to the
parenthetical remark here.
I mean that not only are the
x's functions of y_1 up to y_m,
but they're continuously
differentiable functions.
Now obviously, what we're saying
is that if w can be expressed
in terms of the x's, the x's
can be expressed in terms
of the y's, obviously then,
w can be expressed in terms
of the y's.
In other words, w is some
function of y_1 up to y_m.
Now the question that comes up
is that just looking at this,
I can talk about the partial
of w with respect to y_1,
the partial of w
with respect to y_2,
the partial of w with respect to
y_3, et cetera, all the way up
to the partial of w
with respect to y sub m.
And the question is, lookit.
From the original form of
w, it was easy to talk about
the partials of w with
respect to the x's.
From how the x's are given in
terms of the y's, it's easy
to talk about the derivatives
of the x's with respect
to the y's.
And so the question
is, how do you
find the partial of w with
respect to, say, y sub
1, given all of these
other partial derivatives?
And the answer, again, is
something that you just
have to get used to.
The proof goes through
for n and m the same way
as it did for the
lower-dimensional case.
And the intuitive
interpretation is the same.
Namely, to find the partial
of w with respect to y_1,
we simply see how much
w changed with respect
to y_1 due to the
change in x_1 alone,
add on to that the
change in w with respect
to y_1 due to the change
in x_2 alone, et cetera,
add on to that, finally, the
change in w with respect to y
sub 1 due to the change
in x sub n alone.
In other words,
again, if you think
of this in terms
of cancellation,
if you cross these things out,
don't think of adding them,
but think of them as what?
Giving you the
individual components
that tell you how the partial
of w with respect to y_1
is made up.
By the way, there is
one parenthetical remark
that I haven't
written on the board
that I would like to
make at this time.
In Professor
Thomas's text, he has
elected to introduce
matrix algebra prior
to this particular chapter.
It again turns out
that one does not
need matrices to talk
about the chain rule
but that if one had
matrix notation,
the matrix notation
is particularly
convenient for summarizing
the chain rule.
I have elected to hold
off on matrix algebra
till the near future
because it comes up
in a much better
motivated way, I
think, in terms of these
linear approximations.
But the point is if, as
you're reading the text,
you see the matrix
notation, and you are not
familiar with the
matrices, forget it.
All the matrix is, is a shortcut
notation for saying this.
And if I want a
shortcut notation here,
I don't need matrices
for saying this.
I can say this in terms
of our sigma notation.
Notice that one
other way of writing
this thing very compactly
that may be more suggestive
is the following.
Notice that I'm adding
up n terms here.
Each term consists of two
factors, each of which
looks like a fraction.
The numerator of
the first fraction
is always a partial of w.
The denominator of
the second fraction
is always the partial y_1.
And it appears that the
denominator of the first
and the numerator of the second
always have the same subscript,
but they seem to vary
consecutively from 1 to n.
And that's precisely where the
sigma notation comes in handy.
Why don't we just
write, therefore,
that this is the sum,
partial of w with respect
to x sub k, plus the
partial of x sub k
with respect to y_1,
as the subscript
k ranges through all
integral values from 1 to n?
In other words, notice that
in this particular form,
we have simply rewritten
this thing compactly.
But if you look at
this and look at this,
I think it's very suggestive to
see how the chain rule works.
You see, here's your partial
of w with respect to y_1.
And these are what?
The contributions due to each of
the changes of the n variables.
This is the change due
to the x sub k variable.
And you add these all up because
they're independent variables,
as k goes from 1 to n.
And I write "et cetera"
here simply to point out
that I could have
computed the partial of w
with respect to y_2
instead of y sub 1.
By the way, the recipe would've
looked exactly the same,
except that if there
was a 2 here, there
would have been a 2 here.
If there were a 3 here,
they would've been a 3 here.
If there were an m here, there
would have been an m here.
OK, now lookit.
At this particular
stage of our lecture
today, this could
end with the idea
that for the unit
that's now assigned,
this is as far as
you have to go.
In other words,
for the exercises
that I've given you in
this particular unit,
we do nothing higher
than using the chain rule
for first-order derivatives.
The point is that in many
applications in real life,
we must take
higher-order derivatives.
In other words, there are
many differential equations,
partial differential
equations, where we must work
with higher-order derivatives.
And for that reason, it becomes
very important, sometimes,
to be able to take
a second derivative
or a third derivative
or a fourth derivative
by means of the chain rule.
Now the interesting point is
that the theory that we've used
so far doesn't change at all.
What does happen is that
the average student,
in learning this material
for the first time,
gets swamped by the notation.
Consequently, what
I want to do is
to give you the lecture on
this material at the same time
that I'm lecturing on
first-order derivatives, simply
because the continuity
follows smoother this way,
so that you see what the
whole overall picture is, then
to make sure that you
cement these things down.
The next unit after
this will give
you drill on taking
higher-order derivatives.
What this may mean
is that many of you
may prefer to watch
this half of the film
a second time,
after you've already
tried working some
of the problems
with higher-order
derivatives, if you're still
confused by this.
But at any rate,
let's take a look
at a hypothetical situation.
Since we're so used
to polar coordinates,
let's talk in terms
of polar coordinates.
Suppose w happens to be a
continuously differentiable
function of x and y.
x and y, in turn, are
continuously differentiable
functions of the polar
coordinates r and theta.
In fact, they're x
equals r cosine theta,
y equals r sine theta.
Now lookit.
If all I want to do is find the
partial of w with respect to r,
I can do that by the
ordinary chain rule.
Namely, it's the partial
of w with respect
to x times the partial
of x with respect to r,
plus the partial
of w with respect
to y times the partial
of y with respect to r.
Now, knowing what x
looks like explicitly
in terms of r and theta and
what y looks like explicitly
in terms of r and
theta, I can certainly
compute the partials
of x and y with respect
to r, holding theta constant.
In particular, the partial
of x with respect to r
is simply cosine theta.
And the partial of
y with respect to r
is simply sine theta.
So the partial of
w with respect to r
is partial of w with
respect to x times
cosine theta, plus partial of
w with respect to y times sine
theta.
And by the way, notice that I
cannot simplify these terms.
I cannot simplify
these terms in general,
because all I'm given is that
w is some function of x and y.
I don't know what w looks like
explicitly in terms of x and y.
So all I can do is talk about
the partials of w with respect
to x, partial of w respect
to y, without worrying
any more about this, with the
understanding that if I knew
what w looked like explicitly
in terms of x and y,
I could work out
what this thing was.
Now, here's the key point.
That's why I've accentuated it.
In the same way
that w is a function
of both x and y, so also are
the partials of w with respect
to x and the partials
of w with respect to y.
In other words, even
though this looks
like this emphasizes
the x, notice
that when you take
the derivative
of a function of both x and y
with respect to x, in general,
the resulting
function will again
be a function of both x and y.
And so what we're saying is
that if the partials of w
with respect to x and the
partials of w with respect to y
also happen to be continuously
differentiable functions of x
and y, we could, if we wished,
use the chain rule again.
In other words, suppose
in the particular problem
that I was dealing
with, it wasn't
enough to know the partial
of w with respect to r.
Suppose, for example, I
wanted the second partial of w
with respect to r.
Well obviously, that
simply means what?
Take the partial of
this with respect to r.
In other words, the second
partial of w with respect to r
is just the partial of the
partial of w with respect to r,
with respect r.
I'm just going to differentiate
this thing with respect to r.
In other words, writing this
out more succinctly for you,
the second partial derivative
of w with respect to r
is the partial with respect
to r of cosine theta
partial of w with respect to
x, plus sine theta partial
of w with respect to y.
Now, here's the key point.
When we differentiate
here, we're
assuming that theta is
being held constant.
Isn't that right?
So consequently, when I'm
differentiating with respect
to r, cosine theta
is a constant.
I can skip over that,
see, and differentiate
what's left with respect to r.
In other words, that's what?
It's the partial of w with
respect to x differentiated
with respect to r.
See, I'm using the ordinary rule
for the derivative of a sum.
Now, the derivative
of sine theta--
see, sine theta is a
constant with respect to r.
So the derivative
of this term is just
sine theta times the
derivative of the partial
of w with respect to y, with
respect to r, written this way.
Now, the key point is that
both of these functions
here, both of these are
functions of x and y.
x and y, in turn, are
functions of r and theta.
So in other words,
to differentiate
this thing with respect to r, I
must use the chain rule again.
Now, because this may
seem difficult for you,
all I'm really
saying is, lookit.
If this term here
looks messy, since we
know that the partial
of w with respect to x
is some function of x and y,
let's call that h of x, y.
Then all we're saying is that
the partial of the partial of w
with respect to x,
with respect to r,
is just the partial of
h with respect to r.
But to find the partial
of h with respect to r,
we know how to use
the chain rule there.
It's just what?
It's the partial
of h with respect
to x times the partial
of x with respect to r,
plus the partial
of h with respect
to y times the partial
of y with respect to r.
Of course, if we now
remember what h is-- see,
h is the partial of
w with respect to x.
So if I differentiate
again with respect to x,
I get the second partial
of w with respect to x.
We've already seen that the
partial of x with respect to r
is cosine theta, so
I have this term.
The partial of h with respect
to y really says what?
Differentiate the
partial of w with respect
to x, with respect to y.
And the usual way
of abbreviating that
is like this, which, again,
is explained in the reading
material.
And we now multiply that by
the partial of y with respect
to r, which happens
to be sine theta.
Now, look at this a few
times in your spare time,
if it's bothering you.
It is not really
that difficult. It
is messy notation in the
sense that you're not
used to notation that's
quite that messy.
That's why it's messy.
Once you get used
to it, it is not
any tougher than the chain rule
for one independent variable.
In fact, to take the
partial of the partial of w
with respect to y, with respect
to r, I'll do that in one step
without using a substitution.
All I'm saying is
that this function
depends on both x and y.
So to see what its derivative
is with respect to r,
I'll see what the contribution
of its derivative with respect
to r is due to just x alone.
Then I'll see what
contribution of its derivative
with respect to r is
due to just y alone.
And by the way, when
I say it that way,
notice how quick it is
to write this thing down.
I differentiate
this with respect
to x multiplied by the partial
of x with respect to r.
Add on to that the partial
of this with respect to y.
Multiply that by the partial
of y with respect to r.
If I do this, notice
now I have what?
I have the partial
with respect to y.
And I differentiate
that with respect to x.
That's written this way.
And by the way, notice that
this is the reverse order
of what we did over here.
Namely, in one case, we first
differentiated with respect
to x and then with respect to y.
In the other case, we
differentiated first
with respect to y and
then with respect to x.
So that actually, conceptually
there is a difference.
That's why we write
these things differently.
It does, again, turn
out that in most cases,
the answer that you
get-- thank goodness--
doesn't depend on the
order in which you
perform the derivatives.
But this is not at
all self-evident,
even though you'd like
to believe that it is.
But we'll talk about that more
in the exercises and the like.
But all I'm saying now is that
if we put everything together
of what we've had
before, we can obtain,
in this particular case,
that the second partial of w
with respect to r is this
somewhat messy but nonetheless
straightforward expression.
And see, I've
circled these things
to sort of tell you that if it
is permissible to interchange
the order of differentiation, we
could combine these two terms.
On the other hand, if you
couldn't interchange the order,
this would be a
rather dangerous thing
to do over here because these
might be different answers.
As I say again, if you
have enough continuity,
it turns out that these
two factors are the same.
But that's not the
important issue here.
The important issue
here is that I
can keep using the chain rule to
take higher-order derivatives.
And even though the
notation is messier,
this happened when we dealt with
functions of a single variable.
Remember when we
used the chain rule
to find dy/dx when y and x were
given, say, as functions of t?
We could also use the chain rule
to find the second derivative
of y with respect to x.
But we had to be a little bit
more careful of the computation
because certain factors crept
in that we had to keep track of.
At any rate, again, to
illustrate this idea
rather than to keep
droning on about it,
let me take a particularly
simple computational problem
to check this thing on.
In other words,
what I'm going to do
is take this messy formula over
here and apply it to a case
where the arithmetic happens
to be very, very simple.
I'm going to rig this
very, very nicely.
I'm going to let f of x, y just
be x squared plus y squared,
in this case.
Let w be x squared
plus y squared.
In polar coordinates, notice
that x squared plus y squared
is just r squared.
So w is just r squared.
What is the partial of w
with respect to r, then?
The partial of w with
respect to r is 2r.
And if I now differentiate
that with respect to r,
the second partial of w
with respect to r is 2.
Obviously, one would not use
the chain rule in real life
to find the answer to
this particular problem.
We've chosen this problem
simply to emphasize how
the chain rule would work here.
At any rate, going
back here, notice
that it's very simple to
see from this equation
that the partial of w
with respect to x is 2x.
Therefore, the second partial
of w with respect to x is 2.
The partial of w with
respect to y is 2y.
Therefore, the second partial of
w with respect to y is also 2.
The partial of w with respect
to x is a function of x alone,
in this case.
Consequently, the derivative
with respect to y will be 0.
Similarly, the partial of w with
respect to y is a function of y
alone.
Consequently, when
I differentiate
that with respect to x,
meaning I'm holding y constant,
that derivative will also be 0.
And the interesting point
now is if I take these values
and substitute those into
this equation, what happens?
Look.
The second partial of w
with respect to x is just 2.
with respect to y is just 2.
The mixed partials are both
0, regardless of which order
you did them in.
That's what we saw over here.
So consequently,
according to this recipe,
the second partial of
w with respect to r
is 2 cosine squared
theta plus 0 plus 2 sine
squared theta plus 0,
where the reason I've
written these 0's
in is simply so
that when you're looking
at your notes later,
that traces the analog
of these terms over here.
At any rate, notice now
that if I add these up,
2 cosine squared
theta plus 2 sine
squared theta,
since sine squared
theta plus cosine
squared theta is 1,
this sum is just-- I'll
write that in white chalk
just so we don't accentuate it.
Let it just be
part of the answer.
This is 2 plus 0, which is 2.
And this certainly does
check with the result
that we got the
so-called easier way.
And again, I don't want
to leave you with the idea
that the second way was
just the hard way of doing
the same problem that we
did easily the first way.
I picked a simple example so
you can see how this works.
I'm going to have a
multitude of exercises
for you to do in the next unit,
simply so that you'll pick up
the kind of know-how that will
allow you to change variables
using the chain rule, with a
minimum degree of difficulty.
In fact, hopefully,
I would like to feel
by the time we're through
with the next two units,
you will be doing this
almost as second nature.
Well, we have other
topics to consider
in terms of our linear
approximations and the like.
We'll talk about that more
as the course unfolds.
For the time being, I would
like you to concentrate simply
on mastering the chain rule.
And so until we meet
next time, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.